yo what's going on guys crispy flakes
here with bleach report and for today's
video we are checking out trades to push
nba title contenders over the top this
is an article by grant hughes so when it
comes down to if you guys check out the
nba standings it's such a close race
this season to the point where you know
one or two trade deadline moves can make
a big huge difference as far as
separating your team from the rest of
the pack so let me know in the comment
section below if your team's in
contention what is one trade you would
like to see them make before the trade
online approaches us and as we go
through these trades let me know what
your opinions are on them in the
comments section below but let's go
ahead and get going on this so the first
trade we have is the sixers take a
volume approach and this is a trade
between the 76ers and the sacramento
kings in which the 76ers get body healed
harrison barnes and tyrese halliburton
uh the kings get ben simmons nieng and
paul out of it so
when it comes down to it it seems like
daryl mori is really against you know a
volume approach to a trade uh he seems
pretty just reluctant on wanting a top i
guess before he was the top 25 player
ezra said a top 40 player in the nba
whoever that may be but at the same time
he's you know said that he's not really
interested in like dear fox so
i don't know what one is it daryl i
really don't know man but uh
on paper this actually makes a lot of
sense for the 76ers to do you know you
get the good young prospect and tyrese
halibury i guess he's beyond prospect
now he's just a good young player you
get buddy you get harrison barnes like
all three of these guys are some of the
best three-point shooters on the
sacramento kings um you know you
surround them you surround draw and be
with those type of guys but also the
76ers i think are like 26 in the nba and
bench scoring so i mean by adding on
three additional just really good
players um by default you're going to up
you know just the depth of your team
right so i mean
it makes complete sense to me but uh i
don't really know what they want there
for ben simmons man just seems like it's
getting to the point where he might not
get traded this season and this might
last even longer now from the king's
standpoint i am on the side of ben
simmons and thinking that he is a great
basketball player um i think the way
that he's great is not as attractive as
far as marketing you know uh we as nba
fans we like players that score the
basketball right but ben simmons you
know defensively play making wise just
uh so many different ways that he can
affect the basketball game you know he's
a great player but also at the same time
i don't know how great he would be on
the kings if you did trade away three of
their best three-point shooters because
at that point you are looking at you
know having ben simmons with darren fox
that fit is kind of sloppy uh then you
got rashawn holmes at center who doesn't
really give you any spacing right there
uh marvin bagley's still on the team yo
terence davis so i mean
yes you get ben simmons with dear fox
but you just don't really have the right
personnel it would probably take her a
season or two to really get that team
built in the correct way um to make
benson his floors and that type of
system uh next up we do have the golden
state or go and say cash is in on a blue
chip so this is gonna be the warriors
getting miles turner the pacers getting
james wise and moses moody and b eliza
okay so the best way i can explain this
one right here is
the pacers are getting the better deal
right here you and you're you're getting
a guy that was the number two pick in
the draft that we have not really seen
too much of yet i mean just from a
rebuild standpoint that's a great place
to start um you also get moses moody who
is just also a really you know another
good young prospect that could become
something great in the nba one day uh
via liza probably is just like a salary
tossing or something like that but
pacers like this really just
quick starts or jump start your rebuild
now from the warriors standpoint i could
see warrior fans looking at this being
like you know we don't want to give up
all these young players but
turner is a guy that fits so perfectly
in the warrior system that they would be
crazy not to do this and i understand
the stamp standpoint of like you know
like james wise and moji like those are
guys that are part of the future
but the point of the nba is to win
championships so if you have a move that
can you know
move you up another tier and that's
saying a lot for the warriors already um
i think you pull that off every single
time plus you combine you know turner
with draymond green andrew wiggins
that's by far the best you know
defensive front core in the entire nba
he's faces the floor it's just a move
that makes sense for so many reasons on
both sides i mean even if you're the
pacers
you know i would be open with just open
to like a wise man for turner trade just
straight up like that that's awful i
would probably take that right i mean i
think i do think it's a steel tune
except for the pacers but i think turner
just fits in so perfectly what the
warriors do that makes a lot of sense uh
next up we do have cleveland fills the
void on the wings so this is going to be
the cleveland cavaliers by the way men
shout out to the cavaliers for being
listed in a video of nba title
contenders that are looking for trades
to go over the top because that is
fantastic man i'm very happy for the
cleveland cavaliers team um you guys are
great you guys are great man you know
just i love how you guys have done your
rebuild it's been just really fun to
watch but uh this is cleveland cavaliers
getting arie gordon in exchange for
ricky rubio in a 2022 first round pick
so
yes looking at this trade
um for the rockets you know you are
getting rid of eric gordon and in return
you're getting a draft but yes it is
lottery protected but it's still
something that's great for a rebuild
rubio's not gonna play i do think he's
an expiring contract so with his injury
you know he'll probably never see a
minute with the houston rockets but yeah
like getting away from eric gordon and
getting a draft pick is fantastic now
as far as gordon going to the cavaliers
i mean i think he fits it perfectly with
darius garland and you can really
continue to use eric gordon you know as
a six man off the bench he has somebody
that can come in and at times you know
handle the basketball and play with
isaac okoro or you put him out there
with darius garland for um especially
you know in the closing lineups of the
game and stuff like that it just works
out nicely and not to mention you
combine him with kevin love like as far
as bench players go i mean that's one of
the best veteran benches in the nba like
what more can you ask for as far as
really just trying to improve
you know really any aspect of your team
in the short term so i mean
the cavaliers have had um some
unfortunate circumstances this season
with colin sex and ricky rubio but what
i love about them is that they keep on
fighting and to me this type of moves
shows that they have so much more fight
in them um you know really for the
regular season and going into the
playoffs uh next up we do have the bulls
collect the grand prize there's my guy
jeremy grant um
okay so we have
the bulls get jeremy grant the pistons
get patrick williams kobe white and troy
brown jr okay so
as a pistons fan
i can't be biased right here
i do think the bulls are giving up a
little bit too much i really do man and
the reason i say that is because you
know i would be happy with getting
patrick williams a 20 year old you know
forward that's got crazy athleticism
like that's perfect but um i look at the
bowl standpoint of things and jeremy
grant recently went on the record to say
that he is somebody that doesn't want to
get traded to a team where he's not you
know a focus point of the offense it's a
big reason he didn't go back to the
denver nuggets because on that team he
was a role player so in the short term
going to the bulls it makes a lot of
sense with all their injury um issues
this season it was exactly being lonzo
balls so
jeremy grant is a guy that can help
carry the scoring load you know in the
short term but once those playoffs hit
um you know you don't really want to
have a chemistry issue where all of a
sudden you know demar and zach levine
are the main focus points of the offense
you got vucevic out there too who based
off the matchup can be that third or
fourth option so i mean
if jeremy grant can buy into the system
then yes i this this is a type of trade
i would try to pull off but once again
as a pistons fan
i think this is a little bit more than
the bulls need to give up to get this
done um and plus with lonzo being out
too for some time in zach levine it's
like kobe white is gonna be more
important than ever right now um implies
you know yo shout out to troy brown jr
too man i feel like i'm not talking
about him enough troy bond's rooney uh
troy brown jr is a guy that plays
basketball so yeah man i mean another
tossing piece right there so
i would be ecstatic if the pistons got
this if the bulls did this i could see
it kind of maybe showing a little bit of
desperation in a way they don't need to
be um
i know there's guys like you know like
thaddeus young out there they could
probably get for a lot cheaper and to
kind of fill in that short term void but
also somebody that might be better in
the long term chemistry wise is playing
more of a role player type of role um as
the bulls go for a championship
uh then finally the last trade we have
oh there we have emmanuel thaddeus young
completes the suns man so this is a
trade with the suns and the spurs in
which the suns are getting thaddeus
young and the spurs getting dargo
storage uh nader and also a 2024 second
round traffic if you are the spurs you
do this every single time because
thaddeus does not belong on the spurs
right now so the fact that you can flip
him literally and get a draft pick out
of it and then two guys that uh you know
we recognize them as names in the nba uh
yeah man i think i feel like you give
that a shot then instantly you know
thaddeus gives the sons so much more
like additional depth i mean
at that forward spot you can have a
rotation of thaddeus um cam cam johnson
and jay crowder thaddeus can even play a
little small ball center at times so yes
i really like this move just for the
suns to gain some additional depth right
here and it's always safe to go for guys
like this too and really just a good
idea because we don't really know you
know going into the second half of the
season um how protocols are going to
affect things how that's going to affect
the playoffs so if you are a team that
are that is contending right now
um you want to pull off these type of
trades because even if it's a case where
a guy doesn't play the veteran presence
is a great thing to have but also just
the what-if factor of oh you know like
1-5
cam johnson gets injured this happens
right here you have a guy accounts
professional daddy song that can give
you some really solid minutes at any
appointment he'll always be ready to go
so i love this move right here uh what
do you guys think of all these trades do
you feel like they were fair do you feel
like they were one side let me know in
the comments section below but that's
all we have thank you all so much for
watching and peace out my friends